this is a developer they need to
refactor their code from Legacy to
modern language and they need to
generate code that is tailored to their
company's proprietary code base they've
been given this direction from their
manager with a tight timeline the
developer knows how long and exhausting
the process of modernizing can be to
save money and time ah but they suddenly
remember they've heard about duet Ai and
Google cloud and decide to use it to
help them write better code fast debug
errors and create reliable and scalable
functionality for their company's
website lits observe this developer as
they use duet aai to simplify the task
at hand first the developer opens up VSS
code and navigates to a database
connection function that connects their
front-end website to their backend
product database it's written in C++ and
they're hoping to migrate it to go we
now see the developer open duet AI
within vs code and type their conversion
request in the chat window the developer
is thrilled to be able to make this
request in natural language by typing in
the phrase convert this function to go
and use cloud SQL it is able to
understand the context and function
being referenced all without leaving the
IDE and without having to contact switch
and just like that a converted function
appears the function referenced has now
been converted from C++ to go our
developer is in awe not only did duet
convert the code but it also understood
that their postgress connection needed
to be converted to a cloud SQL database
and since duet a is trained on Google
Cloud specific products and best
practices the developer feels confident
with this conversion and reviews the the
code generated next our developer wants
to generate some code using duet AI they
write a comment in natural language
explaining the function they'd like to
create and after typing out the comment
they click the magic wand and taada duet
not only generated the function for them
but also pulled in specific product
related apis functions and methods from
their company's SDK and codebase we now
our developer celebrating they are in
awe of all the time money resourcing and
training hours they've saved without
sacrificing quality and all thanks to
duet
AI ah what's this they got a new email
to start working on a new project that
requires them to develop a new product
filtering feature to improve customer
experience they are excited to get on
this new project now that they know
about duet they open vs code and instead
of writing the function themselves they
simply write a comment in natural
language click on duet Ai and duet
generates the code for them looking at
this response their jaw is on the
floor not only did duet AI generate code
but you can see that duet pulled in very
specific methods and functions from
their company's code base this is huge
typically writing such code would
require them to look up these functions
which would take a lot of time with
duet's understanding of their company's
SDK and code they have saved time
resources and training hours all without
compromising
quality our developer would like to get
a deeper understanding of this code so
they select the code and click on
explain duet opens the chat window
explaining this code great now now that
the function is all set they are ready
to write a test case duet AI comes to
the rescue yet again they click on
generate test cases and duet generates a
test they create a test case File and it
all seems to work our developer is then
able to copy and paste the test file in
the editor from chat they are happy no
contact switching needed for this task
what a timesaver our developer is ready
to push their changes to production and
ask dued AI how to deploy their
application
success time to celebrate our developer
was able to quickly generate code deploy
and generate tests all without leaving
their development environment and with
all that time saved they can now finally
get around to finishing their craft
project thanks to at AI what will you
build
[Music]
h